yeah uh i have a lot to talk about with
the foundation and i am you know loving
it thus far we're gonna get into that
but as you may or may not remember i'm
kind of a big fan of halton catch fire
and i'm and i have to just bring it up
in every interview with you because of
my love for the series so i am curious
though it streamed for a while i believe
on netflix did you find a lot more
people like tweeting at you and wanting
to talk to you about it when it was on
netflix
i did notice that and i was so it was so
nice to kind of because like seven
people watched it when we were on the
air so that so many people have
like found it
um is so meaningful to me i actually
watched it again
um and it was
it was so
i'm so proud to have been a part of that
show and i had it was so cool to kind of
relive that
what felt very immediate to me while i
was kind of inhabiting joe mcmillan to
kind of look at him from the outside i
found it kind of
moving in a way to experience
his rises and falls him wanting
something so badly and it never being
the right idea at the right time you
know
like
it's such a i think it's the real story
of entrepreneurship it's not just the
people who succeed you know the steve
jobs and the
elon musks but the people who try and
fail i think there's such an interesting
uniquely american experience inside that
we have to talk about foundation though
oh we're going right into it i just
needed to bring it up it's like i every
time i talk to jake gyllenhaal i bring
up zodiac it's like an ongoing thing you
know um he knows that well thanks for
thanks for i'm so proud of it so it
really means a lot to me that you that
you saw what we did there and oh and you
liked it
yeah no i also want to send thank you
cards to the two or three amc people who
kept it on the air even though you know
but anyway let's jump into foundation so
um obviously this is my bread and i love
sci-fi projects like this that have
uh
there's so much to talk about but i have
to say that the thing that really
impressed me was especially in the first
few episodes it felt like sky dance and
apple just said um yeah we're just gonna
spend some serious money bringing this
to life because this is not a um it
looks
big on the screen can you sort of talk
about that
i mean i i agree with you it looks it
looks
you know epic in scope one of the things
i love in the first episode
is the um the the orbital platform and
the space elevator that takes down i
think david goyer does such an
incredible job of you see it from afar
then you get inside it and you go down
it see that you you get really the whole
experience of what that orbital plant
you know the platform is entering into
trantor it gives you such a kind of um
a great visceral kind of experience so
that later in the episode when what
happens happens
it's you you know it
well you know something that is
unfamiliar to us earthbound humans
in a in a kind of more complete way
you know
uh this is
with a series like this that david has
talked about lasting for many years um
is it and again i haven't i have not
read all the books i'm not as familiar
with everything but i'm curious were you
at all nervous to sign on to something
that could last
possibly for eight years or were you
sort of like i love this material
what do you need me to do
well i mean we should be so lucky i hope
we get a second season i hope we you
know i hope people connect with it
um
i'm cautiously optimistic but that's
partly because i
love this stuff too i'm a huge science
fiction fan i'm a huge specifically like
of this like speculative fiction of what
happens to humans when you take them out
of this earthbound you know
con you know confines you know what
happens when you
spread them out through the entire milky
way galaxy and
talk about the val you know what what is
happening on earth in those terms
abstractly you know here i play a
character who is the emperor of the
galaxy the idea is
absurd in a way that anyone would have
control at this scale
you know
of this
almost limitless expanse of space
trillions of people and he decides who
lives or dies
he decides who prospers who doesn't the
technology at his fingertips gives him
extraordinary amounts of information
um
it's abstract the role that it's it's
the office of a god
you know that he and what interests me
so much about this character and what to
your question about
you know the possibility that we might
last multiple seasons is that i don't
just play one man i play a series of men
who are inhabiting this role
and i what i find so interesting is that
although at the beginning of our show
there's this belief that they are the
same man
you know that there's this fantasy
that it is that they are one clion
they are in they they
that's not real you know that's the the
it's not possible they're they are
individuals you know they they you know
brother day looks at brother dusk and
and is thinking
i can do this better than you did i can
distinguish myself from the brothers who
came before me and he's looking down at
brother dawn and saying it is imperative
that you are exactly like me
you need to learn the lines learn the
blocking so that when you inherit this
role when you inherit the supreme power
you don't drop the ball
and the galaxy doesn't fall to pieces
so those are individuals you know who
approach that role and in this first
season you'll see a couple of them
um and it's very
interesting to me as an actor to
distinguish them
to find something subtly different about
them you know the
the cleon who is sitting on the middle
throne as harry selden delivers his
prophecy is like yeah i know what do you
think we do all day
yeah it's all falling apart that's why
we're here we keep it together we're the
one who manage all the conflicting
priorities
i think the cleon who comes after him
is looking at him saying and he believes
him
i think he believes him and he's
terrified of
of that inevitability and is determined
that he's got it within him to stop it
uh
yes sorry i was going to say i
completely agree with what you just said
especially as as
i've seen the the eight episodes and
it's very it's very interesting to watch
you play
him
differently in as the season goes on and
the subtle differences it's it's very
very good oh cool i'm glad that i'm glad
that came off you know you try things on
set and you
you know i you try to keep them subtle
but you know i i'm happy to hear that
that oh no
i don't want to get into spoilers but as
the
episodes
six seven and eight you can definitely
see this is a different person you know
even though it's the same
essentially genetically the same person
but it's different he's different yeah
um one of the things that i love about
this series one of the many things is
that it does not dumb itself down for
the audience you're dealing with time
jumps you're dealing with different
planets you're dealing with so many
different things and it doesn't
you know spend a lot of time with
exposition dumps if you will can you
sort of talk about how the series is not
dumbing itself down
one of the things that yes
one of the things that i love about the
series is that it's not
it's an investigation
really of what it means to be a human
what it what you know where is the soul
located what is math worth you know it
can it can measure time it can quantify
things it can predict as siri as harry
selden um
has created the prime radiant
but what but does it really does it
really account for the changes that
humans you know make does it account for
the outliers um where is it that
spirituality starts to answer those
questions that math cannot answer you
know it kind of it investigates all
these things with i think not creating
without stating an opinion and why
that's valuable is that
it's really a story about us here today
on earth
right it's about us
it's for us it's about us but it's
but it lifts us away from the planet in
a way that we don't it's not fraught
with the triggers
you know that we have talking about
politics or the pressures that we face
here and today so that we can
examine our values
as a you know we can look at it from our
look at it from different perspectives
and
investigate that
you know big idea of what it means to be
human
um i think about
one of the things that that occurred to
me early on when i was reading it is you
know those very early humanoids who were
kind of making their journey out of the
rift valley
and what they would have
you know encountered looking at the
ocean or looking at a very wide river
and thinking it's impossible to get past
that
you know there's there's no
there's no world beyond this world that
we can walk
and what isaac asimov has done is
speculated that we are
that we have gotten past that barrier
we've gotten past the barrier that we
now face of will we ever move off planet
the way that we live on planet right now
will we get to the moon will we get to
mars
will we go past will we learn a science
that can
you know as in foundation fold space and
time so we can instantly
you know hit another point of space and
time
you know
it's fascinating and it and i think it's
like
it takes away the pressures of
that we live day to day now and it
allows us to think about these things in
a more
you know abstract and
i don't know
less anxiety-ridden way you know
uh i am a big fan of your work uh have
been for a while and i'm curious when i
talk to actors i love to learn about
their process if you will and i want to
be specific with you say you're filming
a big scene on a tuesday emote it's
really emotional it's really dramatic
it's something that you know you really
need to give yourself to
how do you typically like to prepare for
something like that are you
days in advance sort of mentally getting
ready or do you sort of leave it for the
day before and channel all of that
energy into
that prep process
do you mind talking about something like
this no not at all i i think that
i only find i mean
i've been fortunate in my career to find
myself doing characters that i'm
cerebrally really interested in
so a lot of my work is spent you know
kind of when i go on walks i think about
the character think about this think
about you know that's how it's like i
don't have to sit down and like learn
lines
i i just
kind of think about it and kind of you
know work on the ideas and that's about
90 of the work and that other 10 is just
trying to get as far away from
lee and close to cleon as possible right
so
that you know that's that work that
happens on set
with this it's like so much of it we
didn't shoot on a green screen or
anything it was all
you know we shot on location we shot on
these extraordinary sets and that helps
you know the costumes help the other
actors are
basically all that work if you can kind
of surrender to that and leave all of
that 90 homework
you know in your subconscious
and just you know
um
try to
you know
move away from
you you know
that's that's the goal there are moments
that i think i get close to it um
not always i try my best but you know i
i
it's an imperfect science what can i say
i listen i i could not do what you do so
i say you know uh one of the things it's
my i think my last question one of the
things that i think that david does well
with this series is you know when isaac
wrote the books it was lacking in women
and diversity and i believe and i think
david did a great job switching genders
and adding
new characters if you will and and
people of color um can you sort of talk
about that aspect of the series
i'm
i mean i can't it's exciting to be a
part of i i can't imagine anyone other
than lula bell playing gail dornick i
can't imagine anyone other than
leah harvey playing silver harden
um
i just you know in a way i don't think
it matters i don't i don't i don't i i
mean that in the like in a this is our
story this is we are this is our human
story you know gail's words at the
beginning of it it's not
it's this is the only story right so you
can look at the divisions between us
what makes us different
but if we're spreading our story out
through the
you know the vast vast galaxy we're
really all the same we're the same
soft-buddied humans who have this
tenacity this intelligence this what i i
don't know whatever it is life spirit
about us that allows us to solve
problems and survive
you know that's what the show is about
there's no colors there's no genders
none of that stuff matters really when
it comes to that you know we're
humans kind of working towards our
survival and there's no guarantee that
we will survive you know where is that
great barrier when is it lights out no
more humans
you know i think that's what harry
seldon is
is is putting out there that there
that there's no guarantee that we
continue
to
to live
you know we have to we have to survive
somehow
i i yep 100 100
100 especially with what's going on in
today's society um i gotta stop there
i'm just gonna say seriously congrats on
the series cannot wait to see episode
nine and ten i wish i had them i can't
wait for you to see it either i hope we
talk again after you do because it is
like
yeah i am more than happy to talk to you
after i've seen the finale and do a
spoiler conversation because there's a
lot i would have liked to have asked
that you know okay good i mean i'm glad
we're not big now because i i really
want the audience to experience it as i
had the chance to experience it without
too much like
you know blah blah blah thoughts about
it you know what i mean i want people to
kind of get in you know ex like let the
story unfold but anyway
until then until we speak again yeah
yeah 100 listen thanks so much man and
congrats wish you nothing but the best
okay cool cool thank you